hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
metaphysical questions that Rene
Descartes is going to provide an answer
for a very resolute answer you might say
as well in his meditations on First
Philosophy is the issue of the freedom
of the will and Descartes very clearly
decides on the side that there is
freedom of the will he also clarifies
what that freedom will consist in it's a
little bit different than some other
people's views on it and all of this is
going to be found in meditation for in
the discussion about the interplay
between the will and the intellect or
understanding when we fall into error
and how that error can be avoided
through the proper use of the will so
one of the things to point out right
from the beginning is that des cartes
way of addressing error is going to
involve using the will to constrain or
place limits upon the will that is a
reflexive use of the will and this is
something that you know in the long
tradition that's leading up to Descartes
was recognized by most theorists that
the will is something that can bear
upon itself that's something that you
might say rather unique to it sometimes
we think about the rational capacities
also doing something like that reason or
the understanding can understand itself
the will can choose how to structure the
will so what is the will Descartes
doesn't give us a treatise on the will
as such but he does tell us that the
will and he's willing to use two
different terms here that historically
have been associated with it Volante in
latin Vohland toss right and leave our
beat in french Libertas arbitrary right
the the choice of the will and the will
itself he tells us that it is a power of
choosing in french a year a capacity to
select or two if you like we want to
stay very close to it elect that is to
to select something out of a range so a
little bit later he will tell us that it
consists in and he does use that that
term their cone c stay right and consist
that in the latin he says that what the
will is is this here we go it consists
only or solely in that we can prove all
do something they are on shows or not do
it so this is the general conception we
can do something we cannot do something
in the latin that's actually even clear
vel for evil known fockin a right to act
in some way now it's something that's
internal to us but it's going to be
externalized in many cases so what are
the the some things that we can do or
not you I mean if we think about
specifics it's practically unlimited and
that's another point that Descartes is
going to make about the will but we can
arrange them under four main headings
two of them have to do with what we
might call the realm of the theoretical
the realm of the
true and the false that is to affirm or
to deny and notice that for Descartes
it's not the intellect or the
understanding that affirms or denies
anything it is the will that does so by
engaging in judgments about what it is
that the understanding puts forward for
the will to consider or we might say the
memory or imagination or the senses or
any of these these other faculties as
well that we typically think of as
cognitive right so the cognitive
supplies the conative or the voluntary
or volitional with its raw material and
then the will operates on it by
affirming or denying he also uses the
term to assert right within the realm of
the practical which is something that
Descartes is is very concerned with we
can also pursue force we've right or
flee we are and that extends not only to
actually pursuing in the sense of
physically chasing after something but
to orient ourselves in that direction we
can desire it we can choose it we can
prioritize it FLE isn't always running
away from something it it also means to
reject to be averse to so we have there
the positive and negative valence --is
of all of our practical life this is all
within the domain for Descartes of the
will so this is quite important to keep
in mind he's also going to tell us that
the will is the most extensive of the
faculties that we possess as a matter of
fact you could in fact go so far as to
say the will is the only truly extensive
faculty that we possess extensive in the
sense of the French a tendu stretched
out to all sorts of things so it's the
most extensive faculty how so it's not
contained it's not you might say hemmed
in or or Waldo off I'm fair me right
it's not
closed within any limits any boundaries
that is anything that you can put in
front of the will the will can go beyond
that so in theory although he says the
experience of the will is quite vague
he's the term there if we think about
what we can in fact choose it goes you
know on and on and on and on we can you
know affirm or deny we can pursuer flee
we can do these in a number of different
modalities and so he says that the will
and he uses these terms here is perfect
parfait and extensive right um is
another way of rendering that ample and
perfect extended all of these things are
things that he says about the will a
little bit later he actually says
something quite interesting he talks in
terms of something almost reminiscent of
an Psalms you know conception of that
than which nothing greater can be
conceived he says that the will is so
great that you cannot conceive of
another that would be more ample and
extensive than it the human will has a
certain kind of infinity to it you might
say so he says that because of this
that's how I primarily know myself who
know that I that I carry or bear the
image and resemblance to God the
likeness of God that's talked about in
Genesis how so well you know God's will
is in some respect more extensive
because he has greater power and he has
greater knowledge so whatever God wants
to happen can happen right and God
having you know perfect knowledge will
will the best things but our will is in
a certain sense as extensive as the
divine will this is very interesting
when we think in
terms of freedom especially within a
theistic context oftentimes the notion
of a divine will or divine knowledge
ends up proving to be a difficulty for
humans truly possessing freewill in de
cartes case that's not at all what
happens so we have according to
Descartes freedom of the will and that
freedom itself is not contained within
limits that's part of the limitlessness
of the will and here we can contrast two
different conceptions of freedom that
Descartes works with but he's not going
to make a rigid distinction between them
but other later thinkers have there's
what we can call the freedom of
indifference freedom where we this is
how we often conceive of genuine freedom
we have two or more options in front of
us there's no external force keeping us
from selecting one of them or forcing us
to select one of them and we can decide
between them going a little bit further
if we don't have any inclination or
reasons or motivation to choose one over
the other then some people think we're
most free so if the choice is between
having a coffee or or drinking motor oil
or you know not picking either some
people would say well you know you like
coffee so you're obviously inclined to
drink the coffee you don't like drinking
motor oil
I've actually tasted it once before well
I'm probably more than once when I
worked on cars and not not something
that I'd want I also know that it would
be bad for me right so there's there's a
sort of dislike on a bodily visceral
level and then there's also knowledge
that that's not good for me I'll take
the coffee right and so somebody might
come along and say oh you're not really
free because you're already inclined
towards taking the coffee that would be
freedom of indifference Descartes says
that that is the lowest degree of
freedom whatsoever it's not
freedom in a meaningful sense instead
what we would want is a different kind
of freedom now what's wrong with this
lower level of freedom he says that it's
actually a defect they fall in French of
knowledge that's what it stems from and
not a perfection of the will the idea
here is if we really understood these
these options in front of us we wouldn't
actually be indifferent to them in any
real case so what's a more robust
conception of freedom wrote you know
Descartes is gonna say that choices are
actually made more freely when divine
grace or natural knowledge inclines the
will to one side or the other this is
the way in which the will exercises its
perfection concretely so he says I know
clearly that the true or good are to be
found therein that thing that that
they're going to be encountered in that
that could be one thing that would
incline my will there so in the case of
the coffee it's not really the true it's
more the good I know that I like the
coffee I know that I can use the
caffeine I also know by contrast that
the bad is going to be found bad at
least in terms of consuming it in terms
of the motor oil so I choose because I'm
already inclined to the coffee
I'm not less free by having that
motivational structure I'm actually more
free because I can follow what's good
for me and enjoy the good all right
similarly when we make judgments about
things we're deciding between two sets
of options you know did this happen
because of that or did this happen
because of that I'm going to make a
judgement the more knowledge I have the
more I'm actually free to choose the
true as opposed to the false it could
also be that Descartes says God disposes
my inner thoughts that way and when he
says God disposes my inner thoughts that
way what we have to understand is not
that guy
you know monkeying around inside of our
heads and putting in fake you know
memories or you know wrongheaded plans
of action or false propositions rather
God is inclining us in the way that we
would want to go already so you know God
gives me a sense to avoid this
particular situation you might think
about Socrates die moan that could
actually fit under this sort of case and
Descartes says we're not rendered unfree
because of that were actually made more
free so the freedom of the will to do
all these important things a firm deny
pursue or avoid and to bear upon itself
and saying hey I'm only going to go so
far not any further that is to place
limits upon itself to direct itself that
is actually enhanced by knowledge
natural knowledge he says or by divine
grace so this is very different than the
the conception of freedom as the liberty
of indifference instead it's a more
substantive a robust conception freedom
of the will the last thing that that
I'll say is that dick Hurtz also
considers the question do I have any
grounds for complaint about my will
maybe God could have given me a will
that wouldn't you know be so unruly that
wouldn't go beyond whatever limits are
established by the understanding and
Descartes says well you know you really
don't have anything to complain about
talking to himself in the meditations
because you've discovered how you can
avoid error it takes you some work but
that's you using the will on itself the
other thing that he points out is he
says this understanding of the will as
as being so great that you can't imagine
any or conceive of anything greater of
that sort any greater will it's also the
case that the will is a unity and you
can't take away stuff from the will
without rendering it not a will not a
human will so if you were to take away
some of the freedom if God
like you know a natural set of governors
in us so that we wouldn't go wrong it
really wouldn't be freewill at that
point so we've got here a little bit of
a theodicy as well in the meditations as
much as the hardest weight to provide
he's not a huge theodicy provider so
that is de cartes conception of what the
will is and how the will is free
you